hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be continuing our coverage and the 1971
came to this tournament between
petrosian and bobby fischer the winner
of this tournament does go on to face
buddy Spassky in the 1972 World Chess
Championship now so far things are even
Bobby Fischer came out with the win in
game number one Petrosian fought back
with the win in game number two and
there was a draw when Bobby Fischer
played the white pieces in game number
three so Petrosian playing the white
pieces game number four gonna be looking
to take the advantage for the first time
in this tournament starts out with c4 c5
we have the English symmetrical
variation then after Knight to f3 g6 we
have
d4 now there's two lines the Bobby
Fischer could go down one would be to
play Knight to f6 this gets into the
benoni defense or he decided to go ahead
and play with pawn taking here on a d4
did not want to get into the Benoni line
so pawn takes on d4 Knight recaptures on
d4 and then after Knight to c6 we have E
for now this is the maroc C bind this is
a set up that you'll see in lots of
different openings most common in the
accelerated dragon in the Sicilian
offense but from black standpoint it's
really difficult to penetrate with the
pawns in the center of the board even if
they push forward with e5 that comes
back to c2 has control of the D file
with his Queen here he can't really do
too much bringing his pawn down here
both these pawns in the center of the
board they can just recapture and have
pawn supremacy here so instead if black
does play something you're typically
gonna see like a d6 move from them Bobby
Fischer decides first to play Knight to
f6 and then Knight c3 followed by d6
Petrosian now continues with f3 couple
different options that he had here but
one thing you do want to avoid if you
ever get into this position yourself you
don't want to play something like Bishop
to e3 holding down this night here on d4
may seem tempting from this bishop you
know the knight takes here and then the
bishop recaptures you have a pretty good
setup but really this losses to Knight
to G
for that's part of the reason that
Petrosian is playing f3 yes it
solidifies the paunch in here but it
does stop this night coming down here to
g4 yes the bishop could also come down
but more than likely the Knights gonna
come down to g4 so it does stop that
Bobby Fischer decides go ahead and take
with his knight here on a d4 and then
the Queen recaptures on d4 Bobby Fischer
now brings his Bishop to g7 fiown
kidding is Bishop getting ready to
castle on the kingside also opens up for
a discovered attack if this knight were
to move here Petrosian brings his Bishop
to e3 this does open up the door for
castling on the Queen side if he wants
to since he has controlled this semi
open file on the D file definitely a
good option to give yourself options in
case you wants a castle on the Queen
side this also makes it it's a little
trickier for Bobby Fischer in the center
of the board to push with his pawns we
already talked about why upon coming to
d5 it's gonna be pretty difficult
Petrosian can capture with one of his
pawns here and he has a lot of
protection from his other material in
this end of the board but now if we see
something like e six where you may not
want to give yourself a backward pawn
with E 5 but maybe e6 can be met with
castle on the King side a lot of
pressure that Petrosian would be putting
on this Center file right here but even
if Bobby Fischer does decide to play e5
yeah you bring the bishop or the Queen
back but it comes back to D 2 this is
protecting the bishop the bishop can
attack on the King side of the board
this is a great square can even Castle
queenside a little bit later but now
black has to worry about defending this
backward pawn here on a d6 with Bobby
Fischer recognizing that although he
wants to push forward where this pawn
decides first to go in castle on the
King side then d2 just doesn't want to
even have to worry about this pawn
coming up here to e5 just solidifying
his position even more in preparing if
he needs to bring his bishop over here
to the King side of the board now the
Queen comes down to a5 we do say the
rook to c1 this pawn here on a -
although it's being attacked it is
protected by the knight here on C 3 and
this Knights not pinned
to the king as it generally would be
this Queen here on d2 is protecting that
c6 just getting more pieces available to
the game
we have b3 just solidifying this pawn
chain probably would have forced
something on the board if instead of b3
we were to see like Knight to d5 you'd
probably see some exchanges on at the
board but instead
Petrosian goes for what I'd consider the
safer route and that is playing at b3
rook to c8 Bobby Fischer just getting
his rooks involved into the game e -
preparing to castle on the Kings side if
he wants to a6 not up to the five we
start to see some exchanges Queen takes
here King takes yes he has taken with
his King but really once the Queen comes
off the board you don't really have to
worry too much about King side safety
that is that the the Queen's the main
piece you have to worry about but now
you want to get your King devolved into
the game so getting into the middle and
the in-game your King and the center of
the board is gonna be more valuable so
that's why you decide to take with this
King Knight takes here on d5 we do see
an exchange on the board and then after
the rooks come off we see that the King
come back here to c1 and then after a
few more moves we see the sides decide
to draw now this is only 20 moves in I
actually think the Petrosian has some
fighting opportunities now I don't think
anything as clear as day both sides are
pretty much even on the board in all you
know facets that you'd be looking at but
still 20 moves in you have the white
pieces I don't think Bobby Fischer is
ever going to win this game but maybe
he's looking at it just says Bobby
Fischer is an extremely talented in-game
player so he decides to go ahead and
take the draw so after four games we're
still tied up both sides getting a win
in the first two games and then after
that having a draw after both sides have
the white pieces so that is game four
it's a short one but we do have to go
over all the games so you guys can see
the entire finals in the 1971 can
determine so thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you guys in the
next video game number five from
1871 Canada's tournament between
Petrosian and Bobby Fischer